Transcriber: Leslie Gauthier
Believe it or not,
many of you are participating
in one of the greatest
democratizations of storytelling
the world has ever known.
And you’re probably doing this
on a daily basis
through the movies
and TV shows you’re watching.
This is a grand democratization
that’s giving voice on a global scale
to the bizarre, fantastical
stories of the unheard.
It’s amazing,
and I want to tell you all about it.
But first, to fully appreciate
everything I'm about to say,
you need to understand how movies
and TV shows are traditionally made.
So for the longest time,
the mainstream media industry has relied
on a closed ecosystem of script writers.
These star script writers are often chosen
to create a series of blockbusters.
And the production house investors
rely on these proven writers
to increase their chances of success.
And you can see the problem here.
A closed network of writers
naturally limits the boundaries of plots.
This is why sometimes you feel like
you’re watching the same superhero plots
and cliché love stories.
But this is all changing.
And it’s changing fast
because of webtoons.
A webtoon is basically a story that’s told
using cartoon, comic-like illustrations.
It’s published in short segments,
usually on a weekly basis
and meant to be read on a smartphone
in five, 10 minutes.
It’s sure to create fun,
bite-sized entertainment,
but it's not like Instagram or TikTok.
Those are considered
as non-storytelling media,
whereas webtoons are storytelling media.
They are meant to follow
a narrative structure.
Webtoons are published
in these open platforms where anybody --
you, me, a single mother in Pakistan,
a teenager in Japan,
anyone --
anyone can share our great stories
to find an audience who are excited
to consume our content.
The whole phenomenon has started in Korea
and now spread around the world.
For example, in the United States,
one of the major webtoon platforms,
called Naver Webtoon,
has now exceeded 15 million monthly users.
This is not something happening
in the quiet corner of the internet.
In fact, thanks to the healthy
growth of audience,
the web story platform market itself
now reaches almost one billion US dollars
and counting.
So I’m a strategy consultant,
and I work with a lot of media companies
and content providers.
And I realize that the companies
and executives I work with
fall into two buckets.
Those who start to realize the webtoon
universe is a treasure trove
of new and fabulous stories just waiting
to be made into movies or TV series.
And those whom I am trying
to really wake up
so that they can fully capitalize
on this phenomenon as well.
So if you asked me to describe
what a webtoon really is,
I would say it’s a multimillion-dollar
megaphone for you
and people like you.
With the eyes of forward-thinking
content producers
who are turning to webtoons,
it’s easier than ever
for the writer in you
to become a blockbuster storyteller.
Are you a “Hellbound” fan?
What about “Itaewon Class” or “Kingdom”?
They all started as webtoons.
Actually, in 2021 alone,
there were more than two dozen TV series
made based on webtoons,
aired across major TV channels
and streaming media with big-time success.
For example, Netflix’s “Hellbound”
is a story about people
who find out when they’re going to die
and if they're going to heaven or hell.
And there is an amazing plot twist
to keep you guessing
who’s getting into heaven,
and who’s, you know, hellbound.
“Hellbound” was originally rolled out
as a webtoon in 2019 and 2020.
Then Netflix picked it up,
and when it aired last year in November,
it hit the top 10 most-watched list.
(Video) (Korean) Do you really think
justice can be served
through man-made law?
(Sound effects)
Hyeonmi Kim: Netflix also made “D.P.”
It’s a story based on the writer’s
real-life experience
in Korean military police.
And, you know, if any one of you
are really wondering
whether ordinary people can
make it big in the webtoon universe,
you would be happy to hear that the writer
of “D.P” used to publish his webtoon
under Ordinary Kim.
The webtoon writers can make
up to 150,000 US dollars in Korea a year,
which is five times higher
than the average income.
This is usually based on the revenue
split between the writers
and the webtoon platforms.
And for those major ones
such as Ordinary Kim,
who make a serial hit webtoons
and crossover content creation
such as movies and dramas,
I mean, they can make, you know,
10 times higher income or even more.
You know what else I really love
about the fact that the media industry
is pulling stories from webtoons?
So many people win
because this new model is interactive.
Web story authors get real-time feedback
from the audience who reads each episode.
So the writers get better faster,
and the media companies don’t have to wait
until after the show is made
to see how it goes.
This new model also helps
with the media industry’s notorious
problem with diversity.
Anyone can be a writer
in a web story platform,
from a fresh grad cartoonist
to a housewife,
to who, you know, who dreamed
of being a novelist one day.
The writers are diverse and creative,
and so are their stories.
One of the popular webtoons
called “True Beauty”
was written by an amateur cartoonist.
It was her first webtoon
and became a big hit that found fans
in close to 100 countries.
Then it was made into TV drama
that aired all across Asia.
It’s a story about a high school girl
who has quite different looks
with and without makeup.
Then the story shows
how she became, you know,
comfortable with herself
and loved as she is.
At the beginning, people didn’t know
who the writer was.
As the show became more and more popular,
the writer got a spotlight,
and it was more surprising that she looked
very alike to the main character.
And she’s a single mom.
Now, not only has her webtoon
and drama become a big hit,
she’s creating a positive influence
by making single-parent society
much more public than before in Korea.
Where to from here?
I personally believe
in a few scenarios of evolution.
For the webtoon industry,
there will be more and more
specialized drawing houses,
which could help with designs and drawing
so that more writers
could provide great stories
without having to be great artists.
For streaming networks,
they will continue to keep an eye
on unique stories starting from webtoons
to web novel,
to classic novel --
even mythology.
Who knows?
Maybe the next big-hit drama could
even originate from an old goddess story
in an island in Indonesia.
The competition to hunt
the best story in the world is on.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)